so what what happens with the uh Izzy uh
prenata fight what do you think about
that um well I mean that's another
confusing one like
these guys didn't ask to fight they did
not there was nothing in the in this
rematch that is a commonality with other
rematches these guys are not trying to
fight and in fact the closest they got
is Pierre got asked by Ariel and Pierre
said I don't want to fight him I came
here to beat him I came here to stop I
came here to show the world but I've
done those things
give me a moment I'll leave the division
he can then take back over me he he did
the reverse of trying to fight him and
then said but he did do me this favor
and I will return it if he wants to
fight me I'll fight him but that was a
demotion and Izzy never stepped forward
said he wanted to fight and all of a
sudden one day it gets announced and you
know if you're in my spot you are kind
of shaking you're like what are we doing
here well if he was always saying he
wants it back I think he came here like
I get the point that I get the point
that we're gonna give Izzy a chance to
be but what if Izzy does then we got to
give him another rematch
fifth time these guys so far like at
some point this is getting weird if
they're not asking to fight I've never
seen Izzy do that you guys please
correct me if I'm wrong I've seen him be
a man when somebody's asking about oh of
course I'd like that remaster I'd like
to he he never demanded a spot on the
show and said before we get going I want
a rematch I've never seen him do that he
came on here he wants it okay he can't
right after the fight yeah but uh but
you've seen tanata I'm bored I'm just
suggesting for you there's not a lot of
commonalities to other rematches and
moreover what do we do if Izzy wins yeah
why don't we do that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay okay okay I mean at some
point these guys have got to say to hell
this was vulcanovsky's problem yeah
vulcanovski didn't burn his boats right
he he didn't burn his he stayed champion
at 145. he knew I can go back if this
doesn't go well I can return and if
volganovsky would have said no take the
belt I'm done and I'm not going back
this is where I'm going I'm burning my
boats no way home yeah he would have
beaten Islam and it's the same problem
that Izzy had when he went to 205 he
didn't let the belt go so he knew he
could return home and I just share that
for you if we're gonna just keep
matching Pierre and Izzy there's no
point to it they both need to come out
and Dana all three of them you come out
and make it perfectly clear to the world
this is for Keeps this is for Keepers I
don't care if you've beaten him four
times five times knocked him out twice I
don't care if it's 100 a piece this is
the one April 14th all the more I will
never book this fight again do you
understand me he has to do that oh wow
what are we doing here interesting you
want the steaks
I just don't know what do we do if Izzy
beats him yeah you can't not have the
third match if you have a third match
God damn nobody asked for the second
match yeah well I think
because because I think the fight you
had Izzy winning the fight for sure you
know I think that that was easy clear
Victory and then he gets caught for sure
and that's what heavy-handed people do
they'll catch people but still it's the
second time though that's right
something that he got that's right yeah
yeah because some guys there's an
urgency right yeah the urgency turned on
in that fifth yeah which appears to it
it appears now that he's done it two
times in a row three times altogether it
appears for pierra that he operates best
when the Barn's in sight when he has an
urgency you know it's very scary to see
him turn to go over to Shara and do the
math hey this is the fifth round I'm
down by four right okay I must knock him
out that was a very chilling thing I've
gone into fifth rounds before and I mean
I'm so exhausted I could never have a
conversation if my Coach was talking to
me I wouldn't have been able to hear you
I mean yeah you were so tired out there
and then he walked him down and this
wasn't like a Michael Moore and and
George Foreman situation he walked him
down boom boom boom and found these
shots it was scary but it it just LEDs
more to my point that he had an urgency
who knew this was it it's the second
time it's the way that he works and Izzy
now needs to have that same urgency and
Dana needs to step in and help this this
is it I don't care if they've gone five
times I don't care if I don't care what
the score is this is it until you have
that you're just gonna have vulcanowski
and Islam again where you get a guy that
goes out and he over performs but he can
go back home anyway what she planned to
do from the time that he signed this
contract there's no urgency that's just
human nature